ça s'est vite au pad donc vous avez huit
médailles on a scanné dans le château
pour voir la pièce comme elle était à
l'époque en 360 degrés comme liszt au
pad est une véritable machine à remonter
le temps entre 15 139 et 445 la fin du
règne de françois 1er
nous sommes dans l'immense vestibule sud
le mur d'enceinte est en construction et
les meubles entreposés attendre
l'arrivée du roi et de sa cour qui est
très intéressant ce château c'est que
l'on n'est pas meublé par très peu
mobile et renaissance
donc en effet sa ferme en avoir
de recontextualiser le château est donc
de voir vraiment comment il était
aménagé à l'époque
la visite continue sous nos yeux en 2015
et aussi en 3d au xvième siècle notre
tablette nous transporte dans huit
salles telles qu'elles étaient à la
construction de chambord si on se trouve
dans le salon de compagnie qui a été
aménagé à l'époque de louis xiv est ce
qu'il va être intéressant avec liszt au
pad c'est de pouvoir remonter le temps
et de faire tomber ce mur et de
s'apercevoir que la pièce était en fait
la salle des gardes à l'époque de
françois 1er
donc le décor a totalement changé à
l'époque de françois 1er en avait de la
pas ici et on voyait l'escalier central
de l'autre côté nous voici dans la salle
du conseil
françois 1er il prend ses repas et
organise des fêtes grâce alice topal en
fait on peut voir le cette pièce comme
elles étaient donc au temps de françois
1er
donc elle faisait plus de 250 m² donc 27
mètres de long est en fait c'est au
xviie siècle qu'on ya fait des
appartements donc pour séparer la pièce
en plusieurs parties notre tablette
numérique donne aussi des explications
sur 19 salles du château et 150 meubles
enfin un jeu ludique permet de récolter
des écus pour avoir le privilège d'une
vue virtuelle de la tour lanterne au
sommet de la terrasse